when you came into some money a while
ago you went out and you treated
yourself and you bought a Bugatti are
you still using you have to Bugattis do
you still use the Bugattis during this
crisis
well you never get in the oh okay
alright shoot you on the street I can't
be eye candy
I'll go sit in my garage and be eye
candy
and just imagine so you sit in your
garage Little Orphan Annie does song
[Music]
tomorrow so you gotta hang on til
tomorrow just ink it up tomorrow
makes me wanna hang on to tomorrow
now you gotta hit that next up there
because my biological father was David
Ruffin from the temptations listen you
know what you know when your your
marriage in your relationship with your
girl is over when you tense up I love
you baby you're the love of my life and
she sucks you back this emoji yeah yeah
yeah oh my just yeah oh jeez yeah those
emojis can hurt your feelings can't they
know young generous coronavirus this
distance I can't take this social
distance I was yesterday
she gave me her elbow really well yeah
she's supposed to do that you're not
supposed to hug your mother so she said
to uh-huh so your point is you you think
that it's your right to hug your mom
okay okay she got sixty stitches bar on
me
oh yeah
what yes okay okay I think we got off
track here I think we got off track here
let's just try and keep okay listen to
me listen to me I have to know you've
got an extended family you're always
talking about your aunt's your uncle's
are you keeping in touch with them yeah
more Lorraine she had a nervous
breakdown when she found out LG's elbow
headed ice-skating no virus this ain't
my first rabbit I still held your elbow
coronavirus a bit hey stop it stop it
just stop it okay well I'm sure this
will be welcome news to e drous Elba
that your aunt is Willy
oh dear ma she no more will be 66 double
D's okay okay so they look like a tire
track this is just me this is the
stupidest you've spread so much
misinformation here except you say the
eat yourself a thing is true go back to
get that G's not my fault okay
okay